hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator
this week i have rather a different kind
of interview
last night i spoke with viatoslav
vakachar
svyatoslav is the lead singer of akien
elsa ukraine's biggest band he's a
household name and an artist who fills
stadia across ukraine and beyond
in 2014 the band broke the record for
the biggest concert in his home country
with 75 000 attending their show at the
olimsky stadium
zviatislav's talents go far beyond music
he has a phd in theoretical physics
he's the first person to answer every
question correctly on ukraine's version
of who wants to be a millionaire
he's a philanthropist and a social
entrepreneur
like a chuck's career has dipped in and
out of politics
in 2019 he founded holos or voice
a pro-european liberal political party
soon after he was elected to parliament
and served there for a year
[Music]
even in normal circumstances it would be
an honor to speak with this man
but these aren't normal circumstances
when we spoke
it was the 11th day since russia had
invaded his country in what has been and
continues to be a brutal and bloody war
[Music]
thank you so much mr uh uh vacation for
for taking the the time in this
unbelievable uh uh time to speak with me
thank you and of course now speaking to
you this is the 11th 11th day of of
conflict uh um
since russia has invaded uh your country
where are you what what can you tell us
about those 11 days
uh today is my
uh i would i don't know i cannot say
anything about war uh in terms of uh
working days and day offs but it
happened to be i happened to come back
to my native city leave to visit my mom
because today uh would be my my dad's
birthday would here live would he be
alive uh he unfortunately passed away so
so we went to the cemetery and it was a
little bit of a private thing but also i
officially joined the the self defense
unit today it was not it was just
question of doing it officially with
documents so i still doing what i do the
previous 10 days i was traveling
around ukraine and visiting many places
in the east namely kharkiv and zappos
and odessa
and other places so we mainly went to
see
uh the hospitals and to visit to to
speak to
to personnel and also
to personnel and also to to wounded
soldiers
uh the other thing we did we i made
meetings with members of territorial
self-defense
also we
did
a lot of interviews and we meet
officials in in in the regions in the
council so
what i'm actually doing i can
in a jokingly way jokingly i just
subscribed it
it's it's a mixture of
of uh
uh
i would say
what marlene dietrich did during the war
and uh
probably
uh a mixture of celebrity
today because because yeah
you do
you do different things everybody wants
to talk to you every once everybody
wants to have a photo with you the fact
that you visit their city which is
bombing which is under bombing now
uh
inspires people
uh they call me from from seized siege
uh cities and watched want me to say
something on whatsapp video just to to
you know
to temper to to increase the tamper and
all that kind of things so
so it's like actually you you inspire
people that's
actually i continue doing doing what i
did in a peaceful time but this time you
don't invite people to buy tickets to
iraq concerts you just go to them
directly and you just spend your money
and money volunteers to bring them
something so it's the opposite but the
essence is the same i give them energy
you give him energy and what how would
you describe their energy and of course
i imagine it's different in all these
different places that you're you're
visiting but what's the mood what's the
spirit of the ukrainians you're meeting
ukrainians
are very furious
ukrainians are very
focused ukrainians
are ready to fight till
the end of war which they want to
to end with victory
so they're not ready to give up they're
not ready to
panic they're not ready to
uh
subverse
and uh
they
they're great i'm proud of my people
i think without i can tell you without
any exaggeration
i think ukraine today is the bravest
nation in the world
yeah i think because who we fight so we
are david who fights the goliath and
actually
and and i think we will win
exactly this
but for the same reason that david
uh you know uh won
uh
won this battle with goliath just
because we have better motivation
and when you're meeting uh these people
are you are you playing music for them
are you you're just speaking with them
uh talking with them what's what's those
things it's mostly that i talk to them
i talk to them things they want to
listen but also sometimes
some truth i think is
they maybe don't think about it but i'm
trying to prepare them for this
truth
sometimes i sing sometimes i
read uh my poems
actually the last poem which i wrote
which is called
uh
where we can where he came from my
hatred
because actually hatred is a very new
feeling for me uh i'm 46 now and i never
experienced any hatred to any person any
people uh
i'm i'm
sort of i'm trying to be a good man
but now i have this hatred in my heart
and it's toxic and it certainly
uh presses you
and it
poisons you and and but i know that the
only way to get rid of this hatred is to
win the war
is that because an overwhelming sense of
injustice about what you're seeing
absolutely
i think that
uh
a crazy dictator who
because of being so many years in in
power
uh lost the feeling of reality
uh imposed a war
which in my opinion at least in europe
it's the biggest and the
the bloodiest affair and the most uh you
know
overwhelmingly horrible thing
that happened since world war ii
and i mean it
wow
and but despite this feeling i've seen
actually you you're doing some really
positive things i mean just like yes
hatred is only for the for the enemy
but this hatred is
uh
it's a strange feeling i cannot tell you
because i'm still a kind person i love
people i
i'm very happy to see anybody but
somewhere deep there is this kind of new
motivation just to
just to destroy your enemy
and i think i'm not alone i think 40
million ukrainians feel the same
completely the same
uh
it is probably
if you can compare it if you can ask
your i presume you're british right yes
so so you can ask your
grandfather or somebody from that
generation how do they feel at first
moments when when when
uh
germany started bombing english cities
it's probably the same
you focused you you're ready to fight
but you you feel some hatred you hate
your enemy
because you don't know why it happened
why did they
why were they dead doing that i mean
what the [ __ ] did they want
and the problem
uh uh
the deep the deeper lay of problem here
in ukraine is that
russians contrary to some arabic world
and israel they are not ready to
recognize the very existence of the
state
so they were masking it during all these
20 something years but in fra frankly
frankly speaking they never
uh
uh
deep inside in their political elite
they never
tolerated the fact that iran is an
independent state
they always treat it as
as
as just lost territory they need to get
back
and they want to impose this russian
world so-called skinnier
in ukraine but the thing is ukrainians
are sick and tired of that they never
they are completely different nations so
we look similar our languages are
similar
but our dnas are completely different so
uh you you for ukraine dignity and
freedom is something they are ready to
die for as we see for russians not so
much because they are afraid of being
imprisoned and that's why they then go
to the streets because at the end of the
day they can stop putting if millions of
people if one million of people goes
uh you know floods and streets of moscow
or saint petersburg it may be over
and
uh just to add to what i see you doing
as a positive thing but ties in with
what you're saying there is that you've
been sending videos uh addressing uh
russians themselves and the mothers of
of of russian uh
um
soldiers am i right in understanding
that
yes because
uh you need to talk to them you need to
address them
your messages and my message is very
simple look it's your children
there is a chance that you stop them
and you do something so so they don't
uh
so they don't become you know tools
uh
bloody tools in the
uh in the hands of putin yes it's risky
yes uh
they maybe go to jail or something but
at least they
will not have bloods in the hearts of of
innocent children
in ukraine
but also
that will save them from being killed in
action in ukraine
and that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna kill them in action
if they come
and our soldiers been doing it for these
10 days they've lost more than 11 000
people so it's it's it's a huge number
for
for the war today i mean it's un
overwhelmingly huge number
and it will be only bigger and bigger
and bigger
uh it's in ten days ten thousand uh what
will be in month or in half a year you
do that you do the math um
and
just to your point of of um the the kind
of long history of ukraine ukraine and
russia and uh is there
how united are ukrainians um are the are
there
those of ukrainians who who are perhaps
more culturally or consider themselves
more russian
is there is there a split there at all
or um 24th of february
completely changed the narrative so
before
we had some people who had pro-russian
sentiments
i assume it diminished uh or vanished at
all so i think 99 percent of ukrainians
are ready to fight and they
treat russia as an aggressor and as an
enemy and they started and those who
hesitated and were had
had doubts
uh they
they actually buried these doubts on
ruins of ukrainian homes
and ukrainian women and children and
innocent people who died there
so
the rubicon
has been you know crossed
so
the rubicon has been crossed for ukraine
ukrainians
and it's very clear
that the numbers of
uh how much western western oriented
ukrainians are now you can see the polls
so 85 ukrainians want to join eu i don't
think that in
eu member countries there is there are
such big numbers
uh 76 of ukrainians want to join nato
and it it it jumped 25 from in a week
joining the eu and joining nato are
two of the grievance putin uh and and
this is in no way excusing what putin's
doing but that's the the the
western-facing uh uh
uh
um approach for ukraine uh taking is one
of his grievances and and in if ukraine
were to join the eu or nato would that
not be an escalation
or do you think do you think that that
would be a solution for we already have
escalation which i don't think can be
even bigger
first of all second we're not talking
about
that anybody will be happy to to get
ukraine today so i'm realistic so i'm
not
a musician but i'm and maybe i'm a
idealist but i'm not a romantic guy so i
i understand that that today is
impossible but the thing is that
ukrainians want it and it's a general
consensus so so that's a fairytale
and bad fairy tale created by putin's
propagandists that ukraine
actually wants to be in russian world
ukraine never wanted actually but even
even
even the second thoughts that had some
ukrainians had now uh evaporated you
know so it's complete it's cohesion it's
unification it's uh
we stand by each other and
and actually it's a birth of a big new
political nation and i'm sure that no
matter what will be the impact of the
war from the military
uh
side ukrainian nation
now is ready to last for the next 1000
years
and seeing that as a sort of sign of
hope i i've seen numbers 100 000
ukrainians have now joined the the the
um territorial army yeah and it's
and they they they come more and more
and more so it was eighty thousand
ninety two hundred it's gonna be 120
probably in a couple of days so we don't
know when the number stops and it and
it's very encouraging
and do you have uh any interaction with
your former colleagues in in in
government and uh is there any
not so many because they're doing their
job i'm doing my job i talked mostly to
roman kostanko who is a member of party
of goals and mp but he's also a former
i don't know how to say it to you
how you call this in english let's say a
sort of navy seal so he's elite a former
former elite uh
intelligence combat officer you know and
he's one of the best in ukraine and so
he's now in one of the cities fighting
nikolaj he's fighting
uh in in combat yeah and he he's doing
great job so he has his own unit so at
some times we talk
i also talked to my friend
uh former generalist sahih rahmanian who
is in ukrainian self-defense in kiev so
these are two people but but i support
anybody actually it's not about politics
it's about winning the war
we can have different opinions on
politics including the politics for
president zilensky but now we all
support him as a commander-in-chief
because
that's what we need to do we have
a task we have a name we need to win the
war
and do you have what are your plans
would you have uh plans for the coming
days
you plan to stay in lebo or do you no no
no i'm coming back to
to
central and east ukraine and i'm i'm i'm
i i'll keep doing what i do until we win
uh do you um
have anything
any message for the um people of britain
and the international community yeah
i have three simple messages first
message thank you thank you for all
you've been doing and you are doing for
ukraine now both you and your government
are doing a great job for ukraine
no matter how is your political attitude
so far to an uh
existing government your your government
i think they're doing great job
particularly in supporting ukraine now
so that's my message number two it's not
enough what we need it's uh planes
airplanes and
good defense systems so we need to fight
russians uh and have equal be
equalize them not only in on the lan on
land but also
on in the sky
and third and most important although
maybe controversial
uh we need
uh and we urge all of you to make a
decision to close the sky of great
because
if you close the sky
the the war is over and i'm convinced i
know i'm just a person private person
but i'm convinced that world war
uh
is less
imminent
when you close the sky
than if you don't because if you don't
there is big chance that uh
in the worst case scenario russia wins
the war and it will just beginning of
night at nightmare for all free world or
just i don't want my my
uh my words to be like omen but but it's
something that i feel either we stop him
now or it's gonna be hitler and 1938
1939
so
i think putin feels power so if he sees
that
this
you know very persuasive and very
definite actions from other countries
especially the united states britain and
their allies
he'll he won't be there enough to
to start the world war three i don't
think so
once again it's my private opinion but
i'm i'm somehow convinced so the more
you push him
the more he's afraid
if you're gonna if you want so deter yes
appease no thanks god no
um if if even if it doesn't start world
war three it's not a danger that would
escalate um the conflict itself in
ukraine and and be more damaging for the
people of ukraine themselves
maybe maybe you're right at the very
beginning but in the mid-range mid-term
and suddenly long-term it will give us
opportunity to win it's very similar to
what you had first during blitzkrieg and
then battle
or england so so you need just first
push you need help
here like you know you had american
ships giving an eight for you you have
other you had other things you just won
the time and then you won afterwards we
need to win the time
um well thank you and uh is is there any
uh anyone else you we should be paying
attention to any anything else that you
think we're not paying attention
sadly sanctions uh
the world has already been uh has
already done a lot of things but we need
more and we need
thank sanctions not to make putin feel
bad but we need
sanctions that will uh touch every
russian and we don't want them to suffer
we want them to give them motivation to
flood the streets if motivation of
killing of ukrainian innocent people is
not enough then probably we need
motivation for their lives to be changed
i don't know if they feel short of just
food in their country they will
understand that they need to stop it
and that's why we need sanctions the
more the better
business sanctions economic sanctions
financial sanctions traveling sanctions
you name it
um well thank you so much and and um i
really appreciate your time
one more thing that we need
we need
we need just moral spiritual support and
i know that many
many celebrities many musicians
including england famous musicians
already contacted us and they
uh propose their help it's great let's
do something together let's do a song
together let's let's
let's see that the whole world supports
ukraine not only military or
economically but
but also in ours and spiritually that's
very important as well
not totally we are here we are here
waiting for you
yeah
um well we're we're here praying for you
and and we'll continue to pray for you
and and pray for peace in uh in in this
unbelievable time and and i'm
tremendously grateful for for you taking
time out thank you very much my honor
are the honors ours
um um well yeah yeah um god bless you
and and um yeah thank you we'll see you
on the other side
dear
thank you
[Music]
you